>> I have people literally making like bone chair memes
for my brother.
>> What do you mean the bone chair memes? How are you this
much of a victim? You have had far worse things done to you.
>> We smoking on any car? >> The bone chair defense
are everywhere.
Chibi Reviews content? Chibi Reviews retiring? Chibi Reviews
gone? Chibi Reviews just posted a video. >> I'm done.
Well, if you missed it, a few months ago this guy was someone
who for some reason his his fiance left him, okay? He people
already don't like him because he's a like
anime YouTuber, okay? And he's openly
and he fights with people about how should be allowed in all
of this. So, he naturally builds up a lot of people who hate
him. And then his his fiance cheated on him with his best friend.
And he came to the internet and he made a video about it and
how he was like like just a lot of embarrassing stories, including
how his entire gaming group, who played he played video games
with his girlfriend and his best friend, and this group of gaming
people, okay? And all of them basically said, uh yeah, we're
we're going to go with the people who cheated. Yeah, like all
of the people in that gaming group said, yeah, we're going to
hang out with the cheaters instead. But then he immediately went
to the internet and started telling like a sob story that was
bizarre.
Very very unfortunate. Not not the right place. Especially once
you built up that many haters, it just never goes well for
>> We smoking on Eddie.
>> Slide for Eddie. >> Thousands of people upon thousands
of people retweeting this and sharing it on in the quotes and
in the comments. >> Desecrating a grave. >> We smoking
on Eddie?
>> Slide for Eddie. >> Comparing me to Hitler, comparing
me to Stalin, you have called me a You have called me a Nazi,
you have called me a pedo, you have called me um These people
want me to >> Slide for Eddie. >> That's That's what
they want. I honestly don't think I can ever repay you guys for
the amount of love and support you have shown me. I think every
single day I will be trying my best to make sure I can live up
to your guys' expectations. >> This guy is This guy is
so As somebody with like who's been told they have a slightly
nasally voice, okay? I'm going to go slightly. Don't push it
further. This guy is like straight up he's all >> I think
every single day I will be >> Every single day I will be
trying to become better. >> trying my best to make sure
I can live up to your guys' expectations
because you guys have legitimately been one of the most shining
bright lights in my life and one of the big driving forces that
even allows me to still be here right now even being able to
talk with you guys. To all those through the screen right now
that has like given me support either through comments or the
silent watchers, people that either let's say leave a like on
the video or just give a view, I appreciate all of you. You guys
have legitimately been individuals out there right now. I'm addressing
all of you individually that
put a smile on my face in the darkest moments in the darkest
times. And you know, over these last few months I've done To
be completely blunt, I've done a lot of soul searching. I thought
about it. There was a moment, to be completely blunt, rip off
the band-aid. There was a moment back in February where I was
so close to just quitting social media, quitting YouTube, being
And the reason why is because of just all the overwhelming negative
emotions I had at the time.
>> I got to be real, it doesn't sound like he's quitting.
I got to be real, it sounds like he's going to keep going and
he just baited with this this title. I'm about to lose it. It
sounds like he may have baited
There's no way. >> I'm It wasn't because I hate YouTube.
It's not that I hate anime, manga, and hate talking about it.
Like one of the biggest joys
in my life
is making content, is talking with you guys, is talking about
anime, manga,
good news, bad news. I I like talking about what I'm passionate
with because to be completely blunt, when I was growing up, I
didn't have anyone to talk with. Like nobody was into [laughter]
what I'm into. Like nobody was >> To be blunt, I was always
a loser. To put it bluntly, I was always a total loser.
I Why did you think you had to say that out loud? Why do Why
do you literally did not have to be communicated, man?
Ain't nobody out here likes this guy. >> anime manga. Like
I was the kid going to school when I went into like middle old
middle school or like elementary middle school and then high
school, I was the kid that would get bullied and thrown into
a locker for talking about Dragon Ball. And I know this seems
like an insane thing to say because obviously we live in an age
now to where
like anime and manga is accepted way more than it used to be.
Obviously, there are still sites where people will bully you,
obviously.
We know this one. But anime is technically more accepted. And
the thought of someone throwing you into a locker for let's say
watching Dragon Ball Z sounds insane in this day and age. But
I was one of those kids and because of that, I didn't have anyone
I could really discuss
anime and manga with, discuss my hobbies with, gaming, etc. Because
obviously I lived in the
in the middle of nowhere basically, and I wasn't able to make
as many friends. So, one of the driving forces
was to basically eventually find a community online. And that's
what drove me to make a channel. A YouTube channel. Why I'm here.
And that happened and I've been here ever since. It's been
since 2013, well 2014 technically at the beginning of 2014.
And it's it's been a long time. And
it's been some of the best years of my entire life. I honestly
don't know what I would be doing right now if I wasn't a content
creator.
I want to be honest. Like
>> I I believe you. I don't Why are you saying you want
to be honest? You said the truest thing in the world that we
all knew before this. >> But back into the main point.
I've gotten a little bit on a tangent here. I was close
to quitting.
And the reason for that
is because there has been not just stuff, let's say
but stuff in my personal life that has been really
Yeah. I You guys know. You guys have already
>> I want I want Chibi to do a little introspection and
realize that perhaps the reason has something to do with the
fact that we know what happened to your personal life. That when
you went on the internet and decided to talk about this, you
opened yourself up to it, okay? You're you're quite literally
asking for it. I am going to be the victim blamer in this case,
okay? I know that's normally a right-wing thing. Why did you
decide to go online and say my relationship fell apart, I got
by my best friend, and then all of my other best friends decided
to go hang out with those people instead of me, instead of comforting
me or helping me. Why did you do all of these things in sequence?
Like these are all the worst decisions you could ever make, and
you just keep making them again and again and again and again
and what that tells me is that it doesn't matter what you do,
you're going to become this thing again. This is who you are.
This is who you've always been.
Right? It doesn't matter if you get off of the internet. Now,
you might as well stay here. At least you're kind of used to
the bullying here. Being a content creator obviously isn't for
him. WHAT ELSE IS HE GOOD AT?
THIS GUY MADE A CAREER OUT OF thinking it's hot to see little
girls drawn That's what he made a career doing. What other careers
does that qualify you for?
When you're dealing with stuff on both sides, it does eat away
at you.
It does eat away at your mind. It eats away at your
at your like just your mental state. To be completely blunt.
And at the end of the day, I know it's crazy to say. I know I'm
a content
I am a human.
At the end of the day, I am just a human being. I am a flesh
and blood talking living breathing human the same as all of you
guys out there right now that is watching this video. If you
are still watching this video, there might only be like a few
hundred watching it right now. If so, well, to the the
Don't compare yourself to me, man. I don't want to be in the
same bucket as you. Come on. I don't want to be in the bucket
with you. Whatever bucket you're in, no, leave me out of it.
What the No, thank you. No, thank you, sir. No.
>> Sometimes the pauses hit just right, man. Few individuals
that are watching this video right now at this point, I do thank
you. Thank you for dealing with my annoying self for this But
back into the point. Basically, you're probably wondering, okay,
so if all of this
all that is what drove me to be a YouTuber and all that, why
would I want to quit? Well, obviously
there was no reason. Like I I was close because I just was so
tired
of the overwhelming negativity.
The lack of like uh uh how can I say?
I wouldn't necessarily say support because you guys have supported
me like I already opened up with this video. But the the the
overwhelming nature of just how many content creators
were trying to run me off the internet. There is a lot. >> I
just uh ta ta ta ta ta
talk about me right now. Oh boy. I'm I
But I'm trying to help I'm not trying to help. I am just totally
benefiting from this guy's downfall. You know what? Go off. Go
off, king. >> have seen that have legitimately tried
slander me, use fake screenshots.
They [snorts] have just labeled me every form of buzzword under
the sun. People have called me literally a They have called me
a Nazi. They have called me racist, transphobic. They have called
me all sorts of things. Any type of label you can imagine
I pretty much have been called it at this point. And the craziest
thing is is how the internet works is that when things start
to spread, when things get talked about it especially if there's
louder voices than me, people start believing that. And so there
is a lot of people on the internet right now >> I think
he'd be surprised at how many people just don't believe stuff
now because of the way this works. It just floods the zone and
people don't really think they know until they talk to you or
or see somebody like really break it down. They'll repeat it
cuz they don't give a [__] But like people like ultimately
where the thing comes from with Chibi is his comments consistently
on young like
an anime. That's That's what the comments come from. And if he
wants to go out and explain the obvious differences between and
enjoying drawn depictions of children in this context, well,
he's welcome to do that, obviously.
But, I don't think it's that far off. It It's far as being like
racist and stuff, I don't know about that. You'd have to show
me. Somebody would have to show me what people are referring
to there.
I I think he's You'd be shocked at how many people don't really
believe the [__] they hear.
Or if they say it, they say it as a part of like a joke without
knowing what they're talking about at all. You can't really be
that angry about people who are just amplifying something for
no
That straight >> Or I mean, you lose your mind, you go
insane like this guy did. Right? If you're If you're mad about
like two follower accounts on Twitter talking [__]
you just lose your mind like this guy did. >> People that
will just instantly think that I'm a raging racist, or I'm a
transphobic person, or I'm a someone that you know, is an extremist
on left or right leaning, whatever, you know, I've had both.
I have literally been called on both sides. And it's just like
it's crazy just how the internet works when you um
>> Before I go finish work, I will drop a truth nuke. There's
only two genders, and there's currently no technology or science
that can turn you into the opposite gender perfectly. All you
do is sterilize yourself at this current time, removing yourself
from the gene pool.
Bro, it's so It's like the laziest
at this point, trying to there's only two genders post on any
platform,
what This is the most worthless take. It's so lazy. It's so late.
It's so bad.
It doesn't even matter if you like think trans people are should
have like a bunch of rights. If you think like It doesn't matter
where you fall on the spectrum of trans rights at all. We should
all agree that this take is stupid. Like it's just stupid to
say like you're saying something edgy or cool. Anyway, we continue.
>> people that really want to kind of prey upon you and
rip you up for a person. And I've realized over time now, especially
in the last 2 years, people will hate you
Like absolutely nothing. And they will use any way to rip you
apart to try to tear you down to the point of where you give
up. You're done as a person for I would assume the essence of
they having power over you or just the sadistic glee that they
can tear someone down. I I I don't know, okay? It may maybe there's
more. But one of the things I've come to terms with is >> It's
mostly just think it like honestly
it's it's you venting about like incredibly embarrassing things
that are like like literally something nobody would ever share
with the world. If that happened, most people they would like
curl up in a ball for a couple weeks and then talk to their family
and like move and figure out a new life or something, right?
They wouldn't go and post about it online. And then after that,
the right-wing grift is just particularly embarrassing. It's
not hard to understand why people make fun of this guy. He says
and does a bunch of embarrassing things. That's like somehow
he just can't understand that, right?
>> I would assume the essence of they having power over
you or just >> He's like a guy who is walking around Oh
I don't even know how to There's not Like the analogies are obvious,
but it's like you're doing something incredibly annoying, incredibly
like off-putting to everybody around you. And then you're going
when people make fun of you for it, you go, "Huh, I guess you
just are sadistic and want to tear people down. I guess you're
just a sadist who wants to tear people down, man." No, stop doing
that weird thing. Stop being a weird >> I I don't know,
okay? It may maybe there's more. But one of the things I've come
to terms with is that people will hate someone
for no reason. For instance, let's say someone has a bad day
and then I you walk up to them and then you talk with them, you
try to speak with them while they're having a bad day, they might
just instantly hate you. And there's nothing you can do about
it. It's just instantly bad end. Like for a video game visual
novel route or something, it's a bad end. And no matter what
you do, that's it. They hate you. And you didn't do nothing.
You didn't say nothing wrong. It's just they were in a bad mood
at the wrong time, wrong moment, and they decided to
hate you.
And that's that's >> This is This is the He's now reaching
for pirate software levels of lack of
It's not good. It's not good. It doesn't go good. You do something
You do something weird. You do something wrong. You shouldn't
tell people you've done nothing weird or nothing wrong. That's
a huge mistake.
That's a There's no bigger mistake than that. When you get defiant
and you start telling people, "No, I didn't do anything bad.
I didn't do anything
Not a good idea. >> of discussion. And there's nothing
you can do to change someone's mind. The other factor I've realized
over time is that people really do like easy targets.
They like
punching bags. They like people that um are safe.
Safe [snorts] to hit. And I've realized especially
especially over the last 2 months, 2 to 3 months, that I am uh
that target. I am that target that is
a safe target to hit.
>> Okay, that one I can agree with them. I can agree I
can agree with them on that one.
You know what I'm saying? I get it. Yeah, he's an easy target
to hit. Yep. >> And coming to terms with that and realizing
that uh there will be more voices that will outcry against me
within time over the years if I continue to have an online presence
is something that did bother me. Kind of kind of does bother
me still. But I'm learning to accept that because as a content
creator, if you're on an online space, you're going to be met
with a lot of stuff like this to be able to uh like you're going
to be met with a lot of this stuff and
you just got to accept it. And is that right? Is it okay to accept
all this like hatred and evil slander whatever even if it's not
true. It's not right. But at the end of the day
there's nothing you can change about it. If society deems you
a target, they deem you an easy target or a punching bag, you're
that punching bag. That's just how it is. And I realized that
especially
in the last 2 days with
>> I okay. I I assume this is we didn't cover it yet, but
maybe we need to go back and cover it. I I asked I asked a couple
people if they knew like this story. I just don't follow Chibbi
all the time, but he had basically a whole another dust-up with
people talking about digging up his brother. He just does it
to himself. I don't know how else to say it. He just does it
to himself every time. He could stop at any time and he just
keeps doing it to >> When everything would happen with
my brother and the I just I'm just going to say millions of people
have seen it. I've seen content creators and I've seen people
on Tik Tok and stuff talk about it already making fun of it which
is
Nobody had to see your brother's grave. Nobody had to see your
brother's grave. Nobody had to know where it was. They I as far
as I know when he posted his brother's gravestone, I believe
he also posted some that basically led to where it was or he
might have even posted the address for it. Like he's he's crazy
and he does these things and it's almost like the real question
is not whether or not he deserves it. The question is whether
or not he's doing these things intentionally to like rage bait
and make people go after him so that he can play the victim for
an audience. I don't know. That's really where the question is.
It's just about whether or not he's intentionally bringing it
on himself. >> I realized that
the the the these people are animals. They they actually legitimately
they they think like like they think because they have this perception
of me that I'm like >> Shamoo, you are an You are a animal.
Do you understand? He just to stop talking about his brother.
He blocked me on Twitter for doing an edit of clips from his
own YouTube. I think he does enjoy He definitely enjoys victimizing
himself. Shamoo, I need you to link me that compilation of clips
right now. I have to see what are these animals saying about
him? What are you animals doing to this poor innocent man
that he is having to contemplate leaving the internet forever?
What did you do?
>> We smoking on Eddie. Slide for Eddie. >> Thousands
of people upon [music] thousands of people retweeting this and
sharing it on in the quotes and in the comments. [laughter] >> Desecrating
the grave. >> We smoking on Eddie. Slide for Eddie. >> Compared
me to Hitler, compared me to Stalin. You have called me a You
have called me a Nazi. You have called me a pedo. You have called
me um These people want me to >> Slide for Eddie. >> That's
That's what they want. >> We smoking on Eddie. >> We
[laughter] are smoking
Dude, THE CRAZY THING ABOUT this is the actual drama. You might
not know this. Shamoo, correct me if I'm wrong. This actual drama
is from like a year and a half or 2 years ago when his brother
died. And then the whole Boruto community came down on him. And
it somehow came back up. How did they bring it back up? How is
this a thing again? We smoking on that Eddie pack again. How?
How is this happening? When she made a joke about his brother
being made into a chair. WAIT, BUNGEE WAS THE GUY WHO MADE THAT
JOKE? So the joke there, if you don't get it. No, it's not Bungee.
It's somebody on Basically, when he says, "Well, why do you care
about me being into
Right? That's what Chibi Reviews says. "Why do you care about
me being into this stuff when it's just drawings?"
And people are like, "Okay, so if it's not like a person or a
consciousness, then we just don't care. Okay, I'm going to go
make a chair out of your brother. I'm going to go dig your brother's
body up and make a chair out of it."
And Chibi really didn't like that, okay? He thought that That
really
And so he he immediately is a guy who's being watched to be made
fun of in in any way possible.
>> Chubby had to go and complain about these things. I
honestly feel a little bad for Chubby sometimes until I start
watching the video. Like I in my mind I'll kind of avoid or shy
away from Chubby Reviews content cuz I'm like I feel bad for
this guy cuz he is so hatable. And then I get into watching Chubby
Reviews content and that entire thought pattern just disappears
from my mind. I'm like, "Oh my god." Okay, this is the tweet.
This is the tweet. It's just a drawing. Compelling argument.
I'm digging up your brother and turning him into a chair.
By the way, this is an AI photo. This is not real. This is an
AI photo. Okay, the guy is the the guy with the the shovel is
AI'd in.
>> Why a chair? I don't know.
I don't know why a chair. Apparently cuz it's the bungee comment,
I'm guessing.
Uh hold on. What did What did Chubby Reviews say here? Is this
deleted?
Relevant. We arrested that nasty Are you okay, literal child?
Oh, I see. So this this guy didn't like that and he says, "Look,
it's just a drawing. Compelling argument. I'm digging up your
brother and turning him into a chair." That's what kicked this
whole thing off.
That's what kicked this all off.
>> But I am someone that's already been I've already had
some of the worst stuff that basically can happen to me happen
to me now.
Like I have people literally making like bone chair memes for
my brother.
>> Is that I will say
for a guy who's this down on his luck
and for the guy who's been through what he's been through
how is that I've had some of the worst stuff done to me. Brother,
how is that even light-years close to your wife cheating on you
with your best friend?
What do you mean, the bone chair memes? How are you this much
of a victim? You have had far worse things done to you. How in
the world are you playing victim over this one? This one is a
little much, okay? It's a joke on Twitter. You'll live. >> Spamming
in the YouTube comments, by the way. You probably seen them.
Um people doing that on social media, obviously to Twitter, etc.
>> I might have to go to Chibireviews' page and open up
whatever video he does where he's like trying to cuz you don't
understand how much he does it to himself. And I wasn't watching
brother, I we have to watch it. I'm sorry, we have TO WATCH IT.
CUZ HE DOES I'M TELLING YOU, THIS is why he does it to himself.
Right? It's good. Chibi doesn't even say it's AI and talks about
calling the cops. My god, man. Bro, since you're the grave is
a picture he posted, right? But the AI the guy is AI'd in. It
is technically the grave, right? >> My brother's grave
being doxxed >> Yeah, he posted the grave picture, yeah.
>> and threatened to be dug up. You know why I'm even making
this video?
Because I reported this post out >> Cuz you can't stop
yourself. Because you'll never be able to stop yourself. It's
just going to keep happening over and over and over again. >> And
I was just hoping it was just going to go away.
But you know what Twitter responded to me with?
No violation found.
No violation found when my brother's grave is doxxed >> No
violation found. Moderator's note, we smoking on that Ekko. The
power of the feds are everywhere. >> and threatened to
be dug up.
And then millions of people [laughter] seeing this post, thousands
of people upon thousands of people retweeting this, and sharing
it on in the quotes and in the comments
of this cheering this person to actually do this horrific act
of desecrating a grave. There's no point in me even censoring
this picture
millions of people have seen it. My big content creators that
already hate me already spreading this around either
I think most people were fairly
a lot of people, not maybe not most, a lot of people were fairly
careful about like wait, is this like somebody took a picture
just to troll him like they went and found it? That's kind of
[__] up. And then once they found out he posted it,
a lot of content creators were just like, oh [__]
We smoking on Eddie.
>> Like people were like, oh [__] that would
be bad and then they realized that he posted this cuz he's insane
and he brings this on himself all the time. And then they were,
you know, >> full tilt >> tweets, quote retweets,
or just tweets in general mocking me and my deceased brother.
It is absolutely horrific and ghoulish just how people are. How
far they will go to try to drag someone down. Because you want
to know what they really want from me? These people want me to
That's That's what they want. They want to drive me to the point
of insanity to be done. That's That's That's what they want.
And if it's not that, which that is definitely what they want,
they want to just run me off the internet. Either A by canceling
my YouTube channel, like completely shutting it down, shutting
down my social medias, completely just being completely done
with it. Basically, their objective
is to run me off the internet, completely silence me, get me
to stop talking.
>> Dude, I hope he's not Well, I You know what I think
happens is he does the thing where he's got like ODD basically
where he's getting made fun of for [__] like this,
right? And his response to getting made fun of for [__]
like this is to lean fully into it because he thinks if people
hate him for something, he should That kind of explains his whole
arc of his career, right?
That like that like basically he gets made fun of for something
and he like leans into that thing. That sort of explains how
you become the open avowed on Twitter, like the number one guy.
And I dude, it's just the worst possible reaction you could have
to the internet. This is on a This is like absolutely the low
cow gene. Like you are You are leaning into something crazy by
doing this. And now people are just making fun of him for his
brother. He's got to make a big deal out of it and act like he's
the victim even though he posted all the info to actually make
this post. He posted the grave site, posted this picture.
Man, it's
it's I don't think he can stop. When he when he says he's quitting,
I don't believe him. I don't believe he would ever quit unless
everybody in the internet loved him. If everybody in the internet
loved him, he would leave because he wouldn't understand it.
That's the only thing that could get him to retire is if everybody
liked his content. And obviously that's never going to happen,
so >> And this this intense like hatred and slander
against me, people even throwing random buzzwords against me
for 2 years at this point now is because I started defending
fictional content, because I'm anti-censorship, because I think
restricting artistic expression within artwork, literature, and
just being able to have it in video games as well. I think it's
wrong to try to restrict that. But apparently there is a lot
of people very unhinged
schizo freaks that do not like what I have to say about fictional
content, and
they really will go to
extra levels to be able to try to get me to stop, to shut up.
And I'm going to tell you you guys have already done pretty much
everything you can do to me. You have called me almost everything
under the bus, compared me to Hitler, compared me to Stalin.
You >> Oh, it's like the same video. It's the same list
of things. >> me a You've called me a Nazi. You have called
me a >> I Sorry, this is also the chimu clip. I mean the
other >> me a [__] You've done every >> I
love Wait, the thing is 100%. Dude, you told us about how you
got How are you going to throw [__] in at the end
when we know that happened for a fact? You just did a a list
of the the worst things you could be called, and then you throw
the one in at the end that we all know is true.
crazy. Why would you do that? Like that's what I mean. He invites
it ON HIMSELF. LIKE IMAGINE I did that list and then at the very
end I said Canadian, which I obviously am and have said as much.
Then you're like, wait, are you all the other things in the list?
It's a weird thing to do.
>> everything you can to put any form of buzzword on me.
I want to tell you I'm not going to give you what you want.
>> I'm not going to run off and leave. Like I'm not going
to give these psychopaths exactly what they want.
I'm not going to do that. Why would I bend the knee
and stop talking about the things I believe in and care about
for people that are this vile
and disgusting? No. No, I will not >> it is. There it is.
There it is. Dude, he won't. He'll He'll just keep making his
He'll He'll never leave. If you're You're making fun of him?
Yeah, he'll You, you're going to prevent me from retiring. Okay,
that works great for me. Thank you. Thank you, Chibi Reviews.
We're happy you'll be here all the time. >> stop talking
about what I believe in. If there's anything this whole situation
has done, it really I think has revealed >> be a a a Ralphamale.
>> people can be about someone that hates that defends
fictional content that is
It really just goes to show how >> Why can't you If it's
really not that bad, why can't you just say the word? Defends
what kind of content?
What kind of fictional content do you defend? Why do you have
to say it like that? Why you saying it like that, bro? >> will
try to kill you over drawings. They will want you dead and your
family dead for talking about fictional content and trying to
defend fictional content, something that is just pixels or drawings
on a piece of They will go to this level, this extreme
to harm you.
I want everyone to understand
bowing down to censorship, you're giving these type of individuals
what they want. You are.
So, that is why I refuse to stop talking about what I believe
in, why I'm not going to bend the knee.
Because why would I ever give these psychotic individuals what
they want? I won't. I refuse to.
So, I will leave it at that. I just it's it's crazy just like
how Twitter thought this post was not a violation of their terms
of service. It's ass backwards. I I'm just going to say it's
it's pretty like it's really ass backwards. But, I can't wait
to see
all the reactions to this video with content creators.
>> I Now I really regret not reacting in the moment. I
actually really regret letting this go for 3 days.
3 days I spent not watching this, okay? >> mocking me and
sharing this >> Yeah, it's 4x this. Now, it's almost a
10 million It's on its way to 10 million >> You know there's
going to be people that are going to do that.
Oh, well. It is what it is. I I'll just
I'll leave it at that.
>> He'll leave it at that. This is what he said about it,
okay?
If you see that post, please report it. The police in the area
are investigating and on watch right now. If you have no idea
what I'm talking about, then leave it at that. I dude,
I'm sorry. If he got the cops involved to chase down an AI-generated
[__]
that's that's just not good. I'm going to come out and say it,
okay? I'm going to be the brave guy who says it. That's a waste
of police resources, man. What the hell?
When he knows that he tweeted a picture of his little sister
before he always talks about how he loves it anime. Oh, no. I
didn't know that either. Continue on. We weren't even done. By
the way, we're not even done. >> They'll be fine with individuals
attacking people adjacent to me
for not even doing anything
I'm the punching bag.
Now, I can accept that role.
But it is hard. I'm not going to lie. Dealing with people trying
to punch back like you know, use other people around you as a
punching bag. It is. It it it is definitely.
And those thoughts of wanting to quit
did appear
like a day ago. It did. But I am someone that's already been
I've already had some of the worst stuff that basically can happen
to me happen to me now.
Like I have people literally making like bone chair memes for
my brother spamming in the YouTube comments by the way. You probably
seen them. Um people doing that on social Wait, hold on. I didn't
actually check. Ask who does this and thinks they're the good
guy.
Bro, he's actually get Wait, there's no way he's actually just
getting all of the support?
Okay, he's got to be grooming the comments really hard, right?
There's no way he's just getting love from India. Dude, there's
no way that the comments are like this and he's complaining,
He's got to have he's got to clear the comments out for sure.
bro all these people are being nice.
That's crazy. Obviously to Twitter etc.
Like it's crazy that he's complaining about how his comments
are filled with hatred. It's just so many people being supportive
which he really doesn't deserve. I'm not going to lie to you.
This is like this guy will always be in this situation, okay?
You're you're holding him up. You can't help him. He will always
be back here he'll always be here he'll always return here. This
is who he is. He is the like loser who constantly overshares
on the internet. That's who he will always be. They don't um
speak out how wrong this is because of because of because of
because of because of because of because of because of
virtue signaling or in this case
There's a lot of people I realize that, despite potentially silently
supporting me, will never say anything to advocate or try to
defend me because
of optics.
It's crazy. It's It's really crazy to see stuff like that, and
just to see how many people in this world is actually snakes.
And honestly, really, I would say just like animals. Like they
they have no morals, no moral compass, or
>> I'm going on a little bit of a tangent,
Like let me back up here for a second. >> Animals. Anim-
These people are animals.
>> to being just done and leaving, but I decided not to
because that is >> Easiest prediction of our lives that
you will never leave.
>> That is the one of the big things I still have. My own
agency as a person. My agency as if I want to continue or not,
and run away. And obviously, the main objective I think at this
point, what a lot of people want from me that they haven't already
done to me now, is two big things. They want me to be off the
internet, and they want to kill me. >> That's That's That's
it. That's lit- >> You are like the best, most reliable
lolcow on the entire internet. Tons of people's income relies
on people just like you not leaving and never quitting.
Either or the internet, all right? Please, keep going. >> totally
the last things that these individuals [clears throat] can basically
do to me. And I didn't think I would ever be in a position in
my life to where I would like have all this heinous stuff that
happens to me, like being swatted,
having desecrations happen, people celebrating and cheering for
grave >> The desecration didn't happen, bro. The desecration
literally didn't happen, >> desecrations, big consecrators
at that. Having people like Hassan literally laughing at me almost
having people basically just label me anything under the bus
once again, easy target. It's, you know, I've been deemed whatever
the internet wants to deem me, and so that's just that's the
label I am given.
But anyways, to make a [snorts] long story short, I don't know
where I would
without you guys. >> Dude, we just went 14 minutes, dude.
What do you mean make a long story >> It's been one of
the roughest
few months, technically, of my life that has fundamentally changed
the very trajectory. I I I just I just butchered that. You know
what? Let let let's talk about that. A lot of people like to
make fun of my speech.
I have a speech impediment. I do. I'm just going to say.
Okay? Well, there you go. I've had a lot of people say the way
I engage with drama and stuff is my fault.
Okay. Yeah.
I'm going to say some advice here. >> Hit me. Hit me with
the advice.
>> Not just me. >> Hit me with the advice now. >> me
for a second. When your family is dragged into something, sorry,
I hit a branch here. When your family is dragged into something
>> He dragged his family into it. He's the one who posts
about his family. His family could be totally autonomous online.
He is the one who puts his family at risk by posting pictures
of them and constantly talking about them in some way. He is
the one who does that. He doesn't have to do that. He knows he
has a controversial presence online, and he still does it anyway.
>> And people tell you stop, like stop speaking up.
That sounds
sounds wrong. Like
>> It sounds like victim blaming. It sounds like you shouldn't
you shouldn't speak. You should be quiet and allow your harassers
and slanderers and people that want you dead to win. They want
you to be silent, so you should be silent for them. I don't like
that. I don't like that mentality of basically
being silent for those that want you to be silent.
And I don't I don't like that. I I I really don't. Which is one
of the big reasons why I continue to speak up about things and
talk about things cuz I think it's just unjust.
And will I ever get justice? Probably not.
But, that is life. And that is how life
>> I'm pretty sure when people talk about speaking up about
injustice, it's
that's affecting others.
Everybody talks about the things that suck for them. That's not
speaking out against injustice. That's saying you're annoyed
by something or you don't like that you're feeling the consequences
of your own actions. You're not It's not
>> Very weird. >> It is
It is an unjust world, honestly. Not fair, but
besides the unfairness,
I do have a lot of good things. Like I I have my good health.
I do have you guys, the community, and my beautiful
And obviously, I have a home I can stay in, you know, I have
electric, water, food, and all that. You know, it's it's not
terrible. I I I could be so much worse. I have good. It's not
all bad.
And I am very thankful for all of it. I
But man oh man, guys, it gets difficult
It gets difficult dealing with uh it sometimes, but I've grown
more I think used to it. And I try to push forward.
What I will say before wrap up this >> Okay, before we
get that final word, he's more used to it. He's getting a little
better at pushing through it.
as of 15 minutes ago, apparently,
the FBI is involved is now involved stop with me. The FBI is
involved stop [__] me.
Finally, guys, he's going to he's in at his closing now, right?
We've watched this whole thing. We're here at the close. Let's
see what he's got to say. >> I'm not someone to admire
or someone to even want to be like. I think that if there is
anything, I'm someone you want to do the exact opposite of. That's
at least what I can say. Cuz maybe how I've handled things over
the years is not the way to go.
>> Oh my god. Oh my god.
Ending on a W. The only The first time ever. Ending on a W. >> But
I will say though,
it is what it is. Will I change though in terms of like uh not
speaking up? No, I'm not going to silence myself. I'm not I'm
not doing that. But for others, it might be better if you do.
Cuz obviously,
I don't wish
anything that I have experienced on to anyone else. Like it Even
my worst enemies, I don't. It's It's crazy.
I'll wrap it up there. I love you guys.
Thank you so much. May all you have a fantastic day
or night, wherever you live.
And uh if you managed to make it this
thank you.
Chevy out.
>> BB out. Salute. 07 Chevy reviews.